deux visions se trouve sur la vie le jeu
vidéo il ya des gens qui ont une vie de
merde comme nous sauf que décide d'en
faire un jeu vidéo carrément bien plus
[ __ ] limite c'est parti get born
naître il paraît qu'on commence tus par
là un jour et qu'on fasse halte doit
rapporter dans la poussette ou là ça
c'est quoi ça on apprend à parler c'est
ça qui se passe
et voilà on s'est parlé étudier ça on
adore 12 + 5 h 2a nos jours bat les
couilles de 17 racines bien là 2,9 ça
fait 3 bien évidemment et 5 x 4 ça fait
vingt on va pas se mentir la puberté
oh mon dieu c'est [ __ ] de moutons mon
gars avait plus du blanc qui sortent du
verbe on gagne il a passé un cap deit
nord le premier rendez vous sur fun non
mais n'en faites pas un vrai rendez vous
sur sur ça je valide je refuse je valide
mais elle est un peu chelou cette
vieille femme était très heureuse et
accompagné par plein de petits félins du
coup vous êtes vous même devenu un petit
charme à savoir être bouffé dormir
bouffer aujourd'hui tu vis seule avec 16
chat et demi et du prestige huit heures
par jour alors donné tout ce dont ils
ont besoin
avec ça va moi je match avec cette
vieille femme direct la psychopathe
audineau la femme aux chats ont dit non
à contrecoeur la reine des neiges ont
dit oui docteur zuber de futurama ça
passe et de ce match aujourd'hui on a un
match fort à le pont bir et si tu spam
ça va forcément aller dedans mais koffi
koffi le café oprean je crois qu'on
pense à et du fromage et du ce to whom
et où il va me sauter dans mes cils
tranquillement mais toi j allais médecin
images mais un 2 sur 5 à ton jeu comme
les ibères qu'un chauffeur était un peu
vilain tu as un fils de [ __ ] tu t'es
foire et a pas seulement emplois' et on
bosse et perdu le job de ses rêves tu as
été poursuivi pour tentative de meurtre
et a passé les vingt années suivantes de
ta vie en prison avec un copain de
cellules qui s'appelle papa ours
bon ça a eu un coût alors ok du café et
du lait et une tomate ne peut pas faire
des recettes originales j'ai compris du
lait mais qu'est ce qui vaut à du sucre
alors ensuite faut se marier qu'est ce
qu'on fait on a un style sur les yeux
mais qd hommage tout mais qui sont
originales ou pas alors c'est moi
confiance s'est dit qu'elle te sens de
la mode a mis ta fiancée hors de cause
elle a pris peur et est partie avec ton
cousin à la ddt
[ __ ] à la ddt bat c'est quoi ton père
était adoptée à terre d'ignorants garde
aux affaires c'est ça si chaussettes et
bas
olala pilar attend donc maintenant c'est
à nous d'avoir des enfants mid life of
the echo sonné 40 est rare il faut une
nouvelle voiture des tickets pour
voyager des poids merde j'ai tout raté
sur le chemin du retour de suite a rendu
compte que tu avais tout oublié donc tu
t'es enfermé dans sa chambre pour
toujours à te demander comment ça aurait
pu se passer différemment d'accord il
faiblesse ce psychologique là quand même
moi quand j'oublie d'acheter des fajitas
au supermarché je m'en bats les couilles
à nouvelle voiture les poils eu les
poils et des bas mais le dic est plus
tard et qui se donne à faire technique
et grant hill road drag and drop qui
s'il faut faire faut les prendre et les
dégager des bêtises [ __ ] il faut tout
en ramenant sa fera bon sacrifices pour
seigneur du feu pour ton premier jour en
tant que baby sitter pour ta pluviers
fille tu as d'essayer d'électrocuter le
premier d'empoisonner le second et de
foot le troisième dans le feu bah désolé
d'être une grand-mère cool arrêter les
enfants de faire de la merde
ok maintenant doit rester en santé aux
combes et des pilules dans nos beaux qu
attend regarde comment elle bouge à
pulse et magnéto là qu'ils se faisaient
plus que n'importe qui mon gars oh
[ __ ] que c'est du basket le papier
vous gardiez ce dunk meurt mais non mais
non tu es ce que je dois faire de
remettre les fleurs je dois voir sa cage
doit on dit que tu as un flat juste
avant de mourir à g peut-on y lire la
suite
et ben voilà c'est bien mais c'est faux
après la ville aux jeux
voilà je veux une petite surprise c'est
gratuit c'est parti qui est ce qu'ils
apprennent la mort [ __ ] on va enfin
savoir
ok donc d'abord notre absents va il est
vrai il est vrai d'autres absents va
quoi bon voter premières secondes des
libertés en tant que fantôme tu as
décidé de te coincer manière définitive
dans un obstacle je m'attends destine à
contempler ta pauvre vie et décision
merle qui nous a menés là haut le
hainaut comme les critiques notre visa
buzet ce qu'on voit sur la terre alors
c'est ça la question on passe ou des
araignées se produit par une ficelle
c'est vrai que le flash
ok pourquoi on doit qu'une note computer
c'est quoi ce délire mais n'y a que du
porno elle mais qu'il est morte ou 6,3
faire c'est ça les nettoyer son historie
après d'amore ton pc a été donnée à ton
fils le plus ça lui a pris un peu la vis
beau quand il au vert pour la première
fois il avait des choses qui l'ont
choqué avis réside maintenant dans un
hôpital psychiatrique
ils peuvent se toucher l'habiter pas
être compute un pardon ça n'a échappé au
kern étoiles historiques ces boat race
on a l'habitude d'en faire sa com après
on met ça en tant que fond d'écran voilà
on est bien on doit protéger une
grand-mère watts mais dans un remake
mais attends c'est plus chiant d'être
morts que de vivants en fait vous n'avez
pas réussi à protéger votre femme du
danger désormais vous n'êtes plus seuls
on va recommencer
on va lui offrir une plus belle mort
[ __ ] allez dégagez les élus sont les
couteaux les ninjas voilà la [ __ ] quel
héros revanche c'est à l'adq aux
artistes de chiens tiens plaît je
refasse un apatride ici ce que j'ai fait
pendant toute ma carrière
parti en fait la fed autant de fantômes
ouais je suis choqué plus dur que guitar
hero quoi je dois clic et surtout
comment ya les notes senior de dance
revolution de la souris simple
énormément dites moi qu'est le moins
cycliques son rythme avec la musique
mais cette musique est plus en rythme
avec six passes championship aux makes
acpo sarrière dès l'appel cloche au plat
talla est bloqué mais non oh là là on le
provoque ans visera un robot sur son
front moya ok je compte sur eux pour
chat est annoncée bien avant il est
beaucoup trop tôt
en plus il provoque collecte qu'est ce
qu'on doit collecter vous m'avez pris
pour le facteur qui faisons colissimo le
lundi matin quoi bastareaud mais non
mais t'es sérieux on passe sans grand
problème je vais pas vous mentir
oh oh oh non mais qu'abuser tâche est en
train de craquer quoi je veux pas mourir
juste pour pas avoir versa butin n'est
passé on ne craint plus rien choisy le
roi à choisy-le-roi excellent soit en
vendant faire soit en vo paradis va pas
se mentir on va au paradis faut monter
des marches c'est super long aux
mondiaux d'arriver au bout est-ce qu'on
a accepté est ce qu'on a le cv qu'il
faut bienvenue au paradis
merci d'accord le paradis si les crédits
de fin c'est ça je proteste et je
retiens de cette vidéo n'hésitez pas
c'est faux
ça vous a plu cette fin mais ne pas
l'aimer ça vous apercevez dans une
prochaine ag bien mais c'est tout petit
jeu très évolué beaucoup d'humour
beaucoup de belles choses
voilà c'est le résumé de vidéos le plus
claqué qu'on ait fait on sera quand elle
a vu autant cette fois cette vidéo chat
pis j'ai fait un pis un peu faible
baisse